in this lesson we're going to talk about
unit conversion so this is definitely
something you want to understand for the
s80 and let's go through some examples
pause the video see if you can do them
on your own and we'll go through them
together so first one is easy and a
second a little bit more challenging so
the first one it says convert 100 feet
per minute two miles per hour so pretty
straightforward and a lot of times on
the s80 you know when they give you
these unit conversion type problems
they're going to tell you like you know
whatever the units are and the
conversion of it's something that you're
not familiar with the basic ones you
should understand like 60 minutes in an
hour and 12 inches in a foot but if it's
something that's maybe not so familiar
though they'll give that to you so first
of all let's start with what they're
giving us which is 100 feet per when you
see the word / that means / so 100 feet
/ one minute per minute that just means
one minute right so that's what we're
starting with we're converting it to
miles per hour so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use a conversion factor
and I know that there is 5,280 feet for
every one mile now sometimes this get
students where they don't know like
should I put this conversion factor like
this or like this you know which way do
i write it well you can't really get
these ones wrong because as long as you
set it up such that the units in the
denominator are cancelling with the new
units in the numerator you've got it set
up correctly and what we're doing is
5,280 feet is equal to one mile so this
is really like multiplying by it one and
it doesn't change the overall value of
the fraction it just changes the unit so
now we've got miles per minute we want
miles / hours right so how many minutes
are there in an hour well we know
there's 60 minutes for every one hour we
know we have it set up right when you
don't have it you know reverse because
the minutes are cancelling with a minute
and so now we're left with what units we
do want which are miles / hours miles
per hour so then all you have to do now
is multiply all the numerators all the
denominators and divide so I'm going to
go to the calculator right now just to
show you what this is so it's going to
be 100 let's see 100 times 60 ok so
that's going to be over here and then
that's one x 5280 x 1 so / 5280 and so
it comes out to about one point
14 miles per hour okay let's go to
example number two so this one says if a
hose can fill a cup in four seconds how
many minutes would take to fill a 100
gallon fish tank okay so my cousin okay
her husband has a huge hundred gallon
fish tank so imagine if you were filling
it with the hose that can fill a cup in
four seconds how long would it take for
him to fill is a gigantic fish tank
right okay so let's um let's analyze
this your first of all now one thing
that they're going to give us and you
know and you would give you on the test
is they were giving you this conversion
factor okay and I just some students
probably forgot but i'll show you here
so you just i'm drawing g four gallons
there's four court that fit inside of a
gallon this is just kind of a way to
remember it and then it inside each
court you can fit two pints like this
okay and then inside of each pint you
know there's two cups and a cup of the
eight ounces okay but for this example
we're interested in the cups so you can
see there's a total of sixteen cups and
one gallon so we're going to need that
conversion factor okay so first of all
they're giving us that it can fill a cup
in four seconds so one cup for every
four seconds right okay so we set up
like that okay then we know we're trying
to get into how many minutes will it
take to fill 100 gallon fish tank well
let's convert from seconds to minutes so
we've got for every 60 seconds there is
one minute right so you can see the
seconds or cancel of seconds and we've
got the minutes here now we've got cups
that we're trying to convert that it you
know gallons into cups basically right
so we know that for every 1 gallon there
are 16 cups so 16 cups for every one
gallon and again you can see the cups
are canceling your writer than I there
okay so you with me so far but then now
this is galen and we have a 100-gallon
okay now you can see okay the gallons
are canceling and we're ending up with
the units that we want which are minutes
the only problem is that the minute
are in the denominator so this is a
common thing that could happen with
students you have it set up but you know
is that it everything is flipped so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to flip
this over we got four seconds for every
one cup okay and then now we've got
let's see 60 seconds for every one
minute ok so the seconds cancel with a
second same thing over here we've got 16
cups for one gallon I'm going to put the
16 cups up here and the one gallons down
here so that way that cups cancel a
numerator and denominator and then over
here we know we are starting with a
hundred gallons anything / want is
itself the gallons are canceling now
we're getting just minutes in the
numerator and that's what we wanted was
to figure out how many minutes it would
take so all you have to do is multiply
all the numerators all the denominators
and devise so I'll go ahead and do that
on the calculator real quick just so we
can verify we have the same answer so
for x 1 x 16 x 100 and that's all the
letter x 1 x 60 x 1 x 1 which is just
working out to 60 so that comes out to a
hundred and six point it's 106 and
two-thirds basically okay because this
point 6 repeating 106 and two-thirds
minutes or you could say 106 minutes and
40 seconds but we'll just leave it like
that so again unit conversions it's
definitely something important to
understand for the s80 review this
lesson if you need to and i'll see you
in the next lesson